big time hollywood celebs making a
mockery of covert rules at the super
bowl frolicking around the big game mask
list without a care in the world while
students in the same state are punished
and forced to cover up inside and
outside of their classrooms the nfl
warning fans beforehand to comply with
all l.a county health and safety
protocols masks were given out at the
big game but few of the more than 70 000
fans were seen wearing them repeat
offender los angeles mayor
eric garcetti once again holding his
breath allegedly after he got caught
mask-less yet again in this photo
it all begs the question when will all
democrats finally give up on mandates
that their biggest supporters keep
breaking it doesn't sound like president
biden will be coming around he says
opposing masked mandates isn't about
freedom
many of those people won't be wearing
masks despite the local law in los
angeles what is your message to people
who want desperately for this to be over
and to be able to resume the lives that
they remember
well look um
i love how people talk about personal
freedom
if you're exercising personal freedom
freedom put someone else in jeopardy
their health in jeopardy
i don't consider that being very
dealing with freedom
and what happens when you try asking
democrats where they actually stand on
the issue
i gotta
tell you that i had a very hard time
getting straight answers out of
democrats on the hill this week as to
whether or not they thought it was time
to lift mask mandates because in part
they're listening to their governors in
part they're listening to their
constituents in part they're looking
over their shoulder as to whether or not
they have a re-election or not so many
of them were like we should follow the
science okay well your governor's saying
one thing the president and the cdc are
saying another which one do you think is
the science it was very hard to nail
people down on that question
okay so i'll start with you dana okay
which is the science well if they were
actually following the science the kids
would have been the first ones to not
have to wear masks
and unfortunately the kids are basically
at the mercy of the teachers unions
which seems to make no sense to me i
actually think it's good news that 78
000 people went to the super bowl and
ignored the mask mandates which means
that basically everybody else can too
except for the kids but that's when the
absurdities will turn into outrages and
also i think about garcetti who had the
nerve to say what he said about well i
didn't um inhale while i was yeah i held
my baby i held my breath
and then he said does that make you
happy
and then he thwarts it again so
basically
these people that are in charge of these
cities they don't care about the
citizens they think they're stupid
they don't care at all about them and
they get to go to the super bowl where
they you know he got a free ticket i'm
sure because he's the mayor and
everybody else is like sitting there
going but my kids still have to wear a
mask and any minute now you're going to
see all these reporters is in terms of
herd mentality they're going to start to
write another round of articles about
the they're so concerned about the lack
of trust in institutions in america and
then they don't have the nerve to look
at themselves in the mirror so jesse are
these people i mean do they really think
that we're stupid
yeah
yes and no because as a celebrity you
have to be seen and you understand that
judge it's actually more unhealthy to
not be recognized when you're a
celebrity than to catch kovid when
you're a celebrity and that is a medical
fact right now how are people
how are people gonna know benefit
or at the super bowl if they're wearing
masks that it's the point is to be seen
and why haven't fouchy and biden come
out today
and shamed all of these people
because this was on what it was a
hundred million people watching flouting
these rules you know these guidelines
are here to save lives judge and to do
that sends a wrong message i'm shocked
that she's not on every single program
shaming these people i think actually
what happens when the people in los
angeles saw magic johnson who has aids a
pretty serious comorbidity not care and
not wear a mask i think people figured
maybe they didn't need to wear one also
i would love
to be able to watch
children host a tv show today imagine if
kids had their own tv shows there would
be a lot of banging on the desk today a
lot of you know do as i say not as i do
kind of stuff because you have 70 000
people shoulder to shoulder screaming
inside and then you can't have 12
children inside without a mask on it
makes no sense the only reason kids
still have to wear masks because they
don't have lawyers in tv shows if they
did obviously this wouldn't happen i
have a new thing what i do with masks i
don't carry one out i don't think
anybody here does but when you don't
carry one out and you go into a store
and then they hassle you and they say
put a mask on you say i don't have one
sorry and they either slink away or they
give you a free mask so then you put the
free mask on and then as you leave you
just take it off and you drop it in the
waste basket and you walk out and that's
kind of a kind of a passive aggressive
way for me to fight the man
well that's that's really well thought
out thank you very much all right harold
what about the fact that biden says that
if you don't wear a mask it's it's not a
matter of your personal freedom
well i think in fairness what he said
was your personal freedom if it
infringes on someone else's health or
freedom but your larger point i get and
i think that
democrats and republicans the country
alike is is coming to grips with the
fact that we have made great great
strides against this virus
we've talked about the numbers the
number 80 percent more have one dose 65
percent or 2 dosed 43 of people who are
eligible to be boosted or boosted
um a year ago i wasn't vaccinated i
didn't get fully vaccinated till the
beginning of april so the conversation
today versus where it was a year ago is
far different and now politicians and
public health experts are really not
dueling as much as trying to reconcile
things i think it will be people we've
said on this show before greg you said
it a few weeks ago that it'll eventually
be the people who will push the
politicians and push
our health experts to tell us when and
where and i should say go faster and how
they're doing things now with kids my
kids are now vaccinated i have a
six-year-old an eight-year-old i feel
far more comfortable going out being out
being social knowing that if i do go
home by some weird chance and transmit
something that my kids are not going to
have to likely not going to be have to
be hospitalized but 12 states blue
states loosening these mandates and
restrictions i think is a positive thing
and i think everybody should take a
victory like president trump and
president biden do you plan on giving
your kids the vaccine they already have
it mine are six and eight so my kids
have been vaccinated since early
december right i i was not i didn't
hesitate at all interesting all right
greg would you like to wrap it up i
would love to wrap it up especially for
you oh thank you i'm valentine did you
get my gift no i didn't i'm afraid i'm
afraid you should i forgot to put holes
in it
we're seeing that's mean
i don't even know what that means i
don't know what it meant we keep
complaining about hypocrisy i think we
have to just admit that talking about
hypocrisy is like talking about oxygen
yep it's just never going to go away so
it's almost pointless um the other thing
is it is about
how who are you to allow
who says what is infringing versus not
infringing the moment you get into a car
there's a potential of infringing a
pedestrian's rights right but you still
get into a car that you see the
president and the media redefining the
idea of freedom that in a weird way when
somebody talks about freedom for example
the truckers it's something like a dog
whistle for anti-vaxxers or even fascism
you should be really
be very wary of anybody who talks too
much about freedom which is bizarre
coming from an american president we're
all about freedom we're also seeing a
new kind of virtue signaling here which
is uh i can do what i please
as long as we tell i tell the children
to mask up then that's my job
every governor and every mayor in every
liberal city has been doing this it's
how famous actresses who have really bad
reputations say but i care about climate
change so i can still be an absolute
jerk so what you're seeing is kind of a
an insistent of masking up kids to
assuage their own guilt they're
basically just encouraging child abuse
so they can continue having a good time
so i don't know i think we live in a
two-class system and by the way we
called this again it was another five
life predictor we said the super bowl
this was going to happen so it's just
declare it over before it happens we
have a two class system the one that
wants to do what it wants and the one
that wants to tell you what to do while
they do what they want we have to crush
that we can't have people telling us
what we can do to our kids because they
believe it's infringing on their a lot
on their lives that is a slippery slope
that just goes straight into something
really bad yeah you would think really
you would think that the burden is you
think that the burden is on the person
you know who has more to lose at that
point but they don't want to do that
they spent they they gave 78 000 k 95
mass away for nothing yeah they could
have gone to actual nurses first
responders that needed them they could
have had a giant eyes wide shut party oh
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else